coming in on this and working with
Ridley what tell us about first of all
how you got to the project and a little
bit about the sort of the nature of that
collaboration I had been working on lost
for six years and during that time
television is an all consuming job we
did 121 hours of that show in over the
course of six years and the only other
movie project that i did was i produced
the first Star Trek film which was great
because we kind of did a TV style and JJ
myself Alex Kurtzman and Bob horsey who
wrote the script all sort of
collaborated between the second and
third seasons of lost and then the
writer strike happened right around the
time that we went into production so I
was able to be on that set and was
really proud of that film but i but but
but didn't write it and then a CAA kept
calling and saying like we have you know
this great opportunity and I was like I
just I don't even want to know about it
don't tell me what it is so lost ended
in may of 2010 and then I went to Italy
to reintroduce myself to my family who I
hadn't seen they turned it they were
doing well we had a lot of catching up
to do and so we we were in Europe for a
month and then I came back and um and I
got a phone call I was driving on
Ventura Boulevard and studio city I just
had a very nice lunch at arts
delicatessen and my my agent called me
and said Ridley Scott's going to call
you in five minutes you available and I
slammed on the brakes of my car which is
what you do when you get that call and
and I pulled over and five minutes later
Ridley called me and I just answered my
phone and there was no pomp or
circumstance there was no assistance
saying I have at least got for you I he
was just like hey dude I'm sending you a
script and I was like if you actually do
calls me dude still I'm not entirely
sure he knows my name and and at the
time I thought it I was like this is a
case of mistaken identity he thinks out
of someone else like David Benioff or
something but I'm just going to roll
with it and I said I yeah absolutely
i'll read anything that you send me so i
called my agent back and I said
you know what this isn't he says I have
no idea so about two hours later a guy
showed up in my house and he handed me a
screenplay and he said I'll be waiting
in my car in front of your house and
when you're finished you can hand it
back to me and right then I was like
this is the alien thing that I've been
hearing about and uh so I'm sure you are
a geek like me We we'd been tracking
that the fact that Ridley was going to
direct an alien prequel for a couple of
years it was on my radar when I got that
screenplay and sure enough the script
was written by John Speights who I share
writing credit with on the movie I've
befriended over the process I thought
the script was great but it was a very
um dyed-in-the-wool prequel so there's
eggs there's facehuggers there's chest
bursters there Xena Morris with acid for
blood by page like 35 like that's what
it is it just happens to take place
before alien but there was this other
amazing original idea in the movie that
I thought that basically sort of gave a
thematic weight to the franchise which
had traditionally either been a horror
movie or an action movie or god knows
what after that and so the idea that all
of this sort of got kick-started by
mankind's desire to sort of figure out
what its origins were I was like oh
here's another question that I don't
ever have to answer it drew me and
immediately and but there was a real
thumb at equate to it and I don't know
how I got an Ridley's radar but I sent
out an email that night basically saying
I think that you can strip away a lot of
this stuff that is alienate there and
just sort of changed the balance of the
script so that it's not seventy percent
alien thirty percent new idea and flip
it so it's 7030 the other way and you
know if you if you if you'll have me
would be the greatest opportunity of my
career and I came in the next morning
and um that they they and that Ridley
for the first time and I've written this
whole speech about how he had influenced
me and how amazing he was and I got
about seven words into it and he was
like all right let's get to work and he
was very kind of he was exactly the
Ridley that I wanted him to be and I
just all they hired me and all through
the process I just kept taking every
opportunity i could to travel out of
body and and say oh my god Ridley Scott
is talking to you right now you you
exist he's acknowledging the words that
are coming out of your mouth please
don't get fired don't say anything
stupid and it's I think I made it I mean
we made it through the opening weekend
he could still fire me but it was it was
a an opportunity no matter what happens
from here I just getting to work with a
real legend and I think that word gets
thrown around a lot and visionary and
icon but he's all of the above yeah
absolutely